[Música]
nosotros son las tres hermanas mujeres
yo soy la mayor risa jimena y priscila
que por ser la menor siempre tenía todo
el cuidado de todos nosotros
y lo que siempre le ha acompañado fue la
creencia que todos compartíamos priscila
es muy fuerte
de la misma forma vivió su adolescencia
siendo ruidosa y popular
le gustaban los retos y ella siempre
creyó que lo podía todo tanto que al
entrar a la universidad decidió trabajar
para tener su extra puso solicitud en un
call center y no le llamaron porque no
tenía suficiente manejo del idioma
inglés por lo que sin pedir consejo
decidió irse a estudiar y trabajar como
niñera eeuu cuando empezó a enviar
solicitudes y contactar familias de
inmediato recibió respuesta en muchos
lados pues siendo mexicanos tenemos
forma de ser amorosos con los niños y en
general inspiramos confianza tome la
decisión de irse a texas cuando empezó a
vivir allá oa cambiar sus hábitos
alimenticios hacer ejercicio me empezó a
adelgazar y empezó a tener más seguridad
sobre sí misma entonces
su mamá de gallina la mamá de texas le
sugirió una página donde podía gente
en ese tiempo solamente tenía una amiga
que había conocido en la iglesia
entonces conocí a varios chicos entre
ellos un hindú literal de la religión
hinduista salieron una vez y no le
quedaron ganas de volver a verlo pues
se puso pesado en la noche y no le gustó
es lo que ella nos dijo desgraciadamente
priscila
olvidó su cámara en el carro del hindú y
tuvo que contactarlo para volver por él
por ella pues en ese tiempo empezaba con
la fotografía profesional
el caso es que nosotros con detalle no
supimos qué pasó esa noche pero ella ya
no supo mucho más de él
con el tiempo priscila volvió a
hermosillo renovó su visa y decidió que
se quería volver a ir a texas paso
alrededor de un año y el hindú volvió
empezó a buscar la una y otra vez para
pedirle una segunda oportunidad hasta
que lo logro priscila aceptó y pasaron a
vivir una especie de luna de miel con el
tiempo formalizaron y priscila pasaba
toda la semana en la casa de china y el
fin de semana lo pasaba en el pueblo de
donde vivía el cerquita del pueblo de
priscila
entonces ella volvió a hermosillo a
vivir y en dos ocasiones se vieron en un
punto una ciudad como punto medio la
relación empezó a avanzar hasta que él
quiso conocer a mi familia puso fecha
priscila estaba súper ilusionada empezó
a cambiar el piso de la casa compró un
comedor pinto la casa para que todo
estuviera perfecto para él y por fin se
llegó el día mi mejor amigo fuimos a
dejar a priscila al aeropuerto ellos
habían rentado carro y no necesitábamos
esperarlos yo lo conocí hasta la noche
porque mi mamá le hizo una cena de
bienvenida
cuando llegue con mi familia lo tengo
muy presente porque al saludar lo leyó
mis tatuajes en sánscrito y quiso
leerlos en voz alta a mí esa acción se
me hizo interesante porque yo todavía no
conocía india pero no me encantó él a mí
no me encantó había una barrera en mi
interior lo observé a detalle y cómo no
hacerlo si era el hombre con el que mi
hermanita iba a pasar el resto de su
vida se fueron a bahía kino a 100
kilómetros de hermosillo en el mar de
cortez parte de mi familia se fue con
ellos durante el fin de semana
mi mamá escuchó que peleaban preguntó
por que priscila le dijo que eran peleas
de novios pero en otra ocasión fue más
fuerte por lo que mi mamá preguntó que
estaba pasando y fue como más fuerte con
priscilla y priscila le dijo que a él no
le gustaba cómo se vivía en sonora que
no le gustaba que tuviera amigos que la
buscaran que le hablaran eso era lo que
lo hacía enojar y que los hacía discutir
con esos hechos mi mamá le preguntó a
priscila si él era agresivo
priscilla le contestó que algunas veces
pero mi mamá no quiso interferir supuso
que eran peleas típicas de noviazgo
se regresaron a hermosillo el domingo y
ellos se fueron al súper pues querían
regresar aquí no al día siguiente
madrugar
en la mañana del lunes antes de irse
aquí no pero si la paso por el trabajo
mi mamá le dejo unos chocolates con una
nota que decía mamá gracias por todo
mi mamá intentó comunicarse con
priscilla durante todo el día
y no lo logro a pensar que ellas tenían
mucha comunicación mi mamá no se asustó
ni pensó nada malo pues sabía dónde
estaba y con quién
el martes en la mañana yo andaba en la
calle estaba comprando un regalo para
una amiga que cumple años y el papá de
mis hijos me habló en mi hijo necesito
que me traigas el carro a mi trabajo y
yo no estoy ocupada voy después
y fue muy determinante me dijo ven y era
raro en el entonces fui cuando llegue se
subió al carro
[Música]
me pregunto cómo estás yo le dije que
bien
entonces yo le pregunté qué está pasando
pues estaba pálido y desencajado y me
dijo priscila tuvo un accidente
y pregúntese murió y me dijo si elige el
hindú y me dijo no él la mató le dije mi
hijo si todos vernos segundos fue en
automático yo no sé por qué hice estas
preguntas pero en el momento en que supe
que él no se ha muerto la idea de un
accidente salió de mi mente y todo el
contexto su cara todo eso que a mí no me
gusta todo encajó él la mató
yo en ese momento no sabía todo lo que
priscila se había defendido
lo que lucho
lo que se aferró a la vida por horas
pero la indiferencia de las personas que
la escucharon gritar
a quienes les puedo marcar y no hicieron
nada para salvarla él pudo más y al
final él con sus propias manos le
arrebató la vida
ahí empezó un proceso que duró cuatro
años donde las relaciones del dinero
hicieron que las pruebas desaparecieran
que el delito se reclasificará y que la
posible condena para este hombre fuera
de tan sólo ocho años equiparable a un
delito cualquiera luchamos como familia
y como sociedad para que el delito se
reclasificará mi papá trabajó estos
cuatro años solamente para pagar
abogados y que la muerte de mi hermana
no quedara
como antecedente para que los hombres de
otros países y otros estados pudieran
venir a su honor a matar a una mujer y
que les dieran una condena de sólo ocho
años
el término fue difícil económica
y emocionalmente es bastante teníamos
que seguir luchando aún sabiendo y
teniendo el dolor de haberla perdido de
esa manera y su paz no aceptaron nunca
la indemnización a cambio en su libertad
ajá con dinero quisieron tapar el
asesinato de mi hermana el camino fue
muy difícil pero gracias al trabajo de
la sociedad civil de mi familia de
activistas como silvia núñez se logró
que se tipificará el delito de
feminicidio en sonora y la muerte
priscila sirvió como ejemplo para que
nunca más un asesinato abusivo y
violento tenga una pena tan pequeña hoy
la ley establece una pena de entre 30 y
60 años por feminicidio
nuestra tranquilidad diego en noviembre
del 2017 cuando el asesino de mi hermana
le dieron 43 años de cárcel
la muerte de priscila la lucha legal
social y mediática que se dio puso en
las mesas en las conversaciones de toda
una sociedad del tema de la violencia de
género violencia que normalizada es
difícil de señalar por quienes la sufren
la violencia es ejercida generalmente
por seres de quien se espera cuidado y
respeto como lo es la pareja
el jefe el hermano como lo es tu amigo
el trabajo es intermitente pero siempre
va en aumento
y esque
la violencia no desde el punto de vista
de fernanda guerra hermana picks de
priscila sino desde el punto de vista de
la ley es toda manifestación es todo
acto
a todas contenta con toda conducta que
atenta en contra de la dignidad e
integridad física y moral por el hecho
de serlo como manifestación de la
discriminación la situación de
desigualdad y las relaciones de poder de
los hombres sobre las mujeres comprende
cualquier acto de violencia que tenga
como consecuencia lo que tenga la
posibilidad de tener como consecuencia
perjuicio o sufrimiento en la salud
física sexual y psicológica de la mujer
incluyendo amenaza de dichos actos
coerción o privación arbitraria de su
libertad tanto en la vida pública como
en la privada y permítanme repetir
sufrimiento
en la salud física sexual
o psicológica de la mujer podemos
recibir ayuda pero necesitamos
tener claro que estamos siendo
violentadas
como el caso de mi hermana hay muchos
casos yo hace 17 años era la novia de el
papá de mis hijos
y vamos de fiesta una noche salimos con
una amiga y vamos en un pickup ya
veníamos de regreso
cuando yo lo empecé a cambiar al radio
el papá de mis hijos ya no lo que el
nombrar la hueva
y
e
estiró el brazo y me empezó a caer se
enojó muchísimo solo para cambiar el
radio entonces mi amiga tan sacada de
onda como yo se paró se bajó del carro
lo bajo le abrió la puerta y lo bajo nos
fuimos a su casa por raro que parezca yo
tenía mucha culpa y como remordimiento
más lástima como que iba a ser él solito
caminando por la calle y como era de
esperarse pues volvió al otro día me
pidió perdón
me dijo que era el alcohol que no se
acordaba y yo pues super le creí
promesas y promesas y de eso mis quince
años de matrimonio tuvo mucho de eso así
tal cual igualito bueno
priscila nunca pensó
que su novio que le ilusionaba tanto
podría llegar a eso ella prefirió
hacer caso a su carita dulce y vivir la
luna de miel de igual a igual prefería
hacer caso a su carita dulce y al perdón
que a la luna de miel
lo hicimos porque vivimos en un entorno
donde así son los hombres donde no todo
es claramente una transgresión en contra
de nuestra integridad las mujeres
debemos de tener claro dónde están los
límites y terminar con la permisibilidad
que engendra
manipuladores golpeadores y asesinos
los hombres deben de tener claro que
cuando los límites están claros no se
empujan
[Música]
no sé no se esfuerzan hasta llevar
llevar hasta pensar a dónde pueden
llegar
el círculo de la violencia tiene tres
etapas
la primera es acumulación de la atención
porque sales porque tienes amigos porque
llegas tarde porque te tomas una copa
la segunda es
la explosión de la violencia donde hay
golpes donde ya hay gritos donde te
ignoran o ejercen violencia económica o
psicológica y la tercera que es donde
todos todas caemos se llama la luna de
miel que es donde están los perdones
donde te compran cosas te llevan de
viaje te prometen y prometen y prometen
y tú vuelves a creer
las víctimas y los agresores no tienen
características específicas una víctima
puede ser una mujer ama de casa de 40
años o puede ser un estudiante de 15 una
profesionista de cualquier religión o
situación social el agresor por lo
general es bien visto como
como padre como empleado como vecino
y
en nosotros las mujeres está
que todo eso cambie y la única manera de
lograrlo es cambiar por completo nuestro
pensamiento de forma colectiva
esto quiere decir que lo tenemos que
hacer en grupo yo hoy estoy trabajando
con mi visión con mi confianza con mi
protagonismo estoy tratando de estar
bien para ayudar a otras mujeres hacer
cambios positivos de las situaciones que
vivimos después de tantos años después
de haber perdido a mi hermana yo ya no
quiero más lunas de miel ya no podemos
permitir más lunas de miel
[Aplausos]